[Music]  it's amazing how people can't  differentiate between say the narrow AI  that you know allows a car to figure out  what a lane line is and and and you know  and navigate streets versus general  intelligence like these are just very  different things like your toaster and  your computer or both machines but once  much more sophisticated than another  you're confident with Tesla you can  create the world's best toaster world's  best toaster yes but with the world's  best self-driving I'm I yes I do to me  right now this seems game set match I  don't know I mean that's how I almost be  complacent overconfident but that's what  it appears that is just literally what  it how it appears right now I could be  wrong but it appears to be the case that  Tesla is vastly ahead of everyone  you